I look back at things we were putting
out and I personally was saying and
doing and mid late February and I just
cringe it's amazing in this first
episode of the new series I thought we
might step back to think about the
economics of the coronavirus how
economists have responded to this very
different kind of shock to the global
economy and whether the right advice has
been getting to governments as they try
to cushion the blow one of the best
people I could think of for talking
about all that was my old friend Adam
Posen who's been president of the
Peterson Institute for International
Economics since 2013 and also served for
a while on the Bank of England's
interest rate setting committee Adam
thanks very much for being with us from
your mind office we are all living in a
very different world from a couple of
months ago or even a few weeks ago how
do you think economists have done in
first risks of assessing this shock and
then thinking about how we respond to it
I think you kind of display both the
strengths and the strength of being
relatively empirical and perhaps people
surprised any agreement on some basic
principles in a policy context is very
evident there is 99% agreement that
government had to be involved it
couldn't be just the central bank's and
we had to think in terms of centrist and
bridge loans and job preserving programs
onion credits but of course as you well
recognize I do to my shame cringing if
you look back to what economists were
talking about including myself in early
February mid February you know we were
not seeing this coming our ability to
forecast our ability to think about what
kinds of shocks are having when remains
very well
and the one of the big bits of advice I
guess that's particularly you could see
it particularly in the European
government's efforts is this effort to
if you like hold the economy in
suspended animation
you know everything that the sort of
bottom has fallen out of demand and
obviously a lot of businesses feeling
that they will go under very quickly
seeing the kind of fall and spin the
kind of fall in revenues that you don't
get even in a really deep recession
talking about 90% or 100% cases rather
than even the worst kind of recession
which might see 20 or 30 percent fallen
in demand with the economists have
basically said now what you have to do
is is do what you can to fill that hole
that's been blown into the economy so
that the economy is then intact when you
come out the other side do you think we
I mean we can we know what we should be
trying to do in principle do you think
in practice we're going to be able to do
that I think you've hit the profound
insights there which is even more than
the usual recession this is something
where there's rubb sudden stop and who
falls apart in terms of businesses and
jobs depends entirely on cash flow at
that moment it's not about sort of merit
did you have a good product did you
invest did you save enough it's really
just the side the economic death is do
you have cash right now or do you happen
to be in the wrong place and so the
response that we put together and I
should say we I mean the community is
put together is really one about
providing essentially a bridge well it's
the goal to say don't foreclose the
mortgages don't foreclose on loans don't
put people off of jobs if you can hold
on to them if we the government we
public fund you to keep those jobs
because there is this reality that once
something goes under it's a company if
it's a job place and people leave that
it's very hard to rebuild some people
have said that we may see a reset in our
approach to government and our what kind
of role the government should have maybe
it should be offering always having an
offering more safety net to people in
the gig economy
for example will this different attitude
towards government change do you think
even in somewhere like the u.s. I think
it will I think they'll be pressure in
that direction and I'm hopeful but I
also think this is going to be much more
contentious I think that there will be
I'm already talking to people who say
again not completely and reasonably well
we don't want to communist the system
permanent ownership of government of all
the main industries but I certainly
believe the US has a real opportunity
and a real reason now to move towards
more safety net as you say for its
workers for its people and I think also
what's become very clear with the
changes the unemployment regime in the
u.s. is that we do have a lot to learn
from Europe that you need to make it so
the jobs are not as fragile as low
connection as you mentioned Gate workers
informal sector part-time people but
also even full-time people in the US
tend to have much more tenuous support
and connection to do their jobs the
lower end of the income scale that
should change impatient thank you very
much thanks for having me
you
you